the guggenheim museum bilbao the
spectacular architecture draws large
numbers of visitors making it crucial to
the local economy in spain's basque
country we came all the way over here
from Vancouver Canada just to see the
museum I love the temporary exhibitions
they breathe life into the museum we
will for me the museum is beautiful
aspirational and inspiring
curvy shapes straight and flat elements
too it's very interesting the museum
also showcases art works outdoors jeff
koons puppy is a particular favorite and
many are fascinated by Louise Bourgeois
huge spider sculpture maman inside the
museum more cutting-edge 20th and 21st
century artworks await the visitors the
eleven thousand square meters of
exhibition space draw in the crowds with
temporary exhibitions of high-profile
names like textile artist ani Alba's
or video artists bill viola
[Music]
Richard Serra's remarkable walk in steel
sculptures are part of the museum's own
permanent collection but visitors don't
come only for the art there's also
exquisite basque food the Guggenheim in
Bilbao is the first Guggenheim to offer
Michelin star cuisine
the museum run by Bilbao native Juan
Ignacio de Arte is a success story
[Music]
maybe that's because the museum let's
visitors establish a kind of
relationship to the artwork that isn't
possible in any other museum in the
world the architecture plays an
important role it's allowed us to
showcase modern art in a unique way the
awe-inspiring building marked a pinnacle
in the career of US Canadian architect
Frank Gehry after four years of
construction work it was inaugurated in
1997 as a spin-off of New York's
Guggenheim Museum it was a risky
undertaking in the 1990s when Bilbao was
grappling with a decline in its local
coal and steel industries not exactly
fertile ground for an art museum
wasn't one dramas coming Matthew oh this
was an old city with an economy
traditionally geared to steel and
shipbuilding industries were in decline
but unemployment was rampant socially
environmentally and economically lay in
ruin teníamos una tira Estrada today
Bilbao is considered a prime example of
a city rejuvenated by investment in
architecture and infrastructure its
prospered from tourism a phenomenon
that's been dubbed the Bilbao effect and
more cultural institutions are coming
like the oskins intro a venue renovated
by French designer Philippe Starck
our Mozeliak do you use the term Bilbao
effect to describe the process of reform
and a transformation of the city reform
I prefer watching the Lafitte the
environmental social economic and
cultural dimensions of this process the
Bilbao effect has admirers who want to
copy it all over the world and when did
it happen
locals say the Guggenheim Bilbao put
their City on the world map with 1.2
million visitors last year the museum
surpassed numbers for New York's
original Guggenheim that's generated
thousands of jobs in Bilbao but to stay
successful the museum has to remain
creative I think the digitalization
helps us connect with the public that
way people can access our collections
virtually and prepare their visits
before coming the museum needs to
continue pursuing this path pero no
tiene que shahida on thunder
intersession people to celebrate the
museum's 20th anniversary in October
light artists projected images from
bilbao's Industrial Age onto the
building's exterior
the past meets a glowing future at the
Guggenheim Bilbao